Good morning, John.
Thank you so much for your video on Monday.
It felt like there was this hole, and Nerdfighteria
had been asking us this question for so long,
and we had left it unanswered, and it felt
very... it felt kinda wrong. It felt kinda
like a gap in our body of work.
And it points out that often, asking questions
about the questions that we want to ask is
far more useful than answering the questions
themselves. So for example, interesting question
about the phrase "belief in God." There are
more words that are hard to define in that
sentence than words are easy to define.
For example, "God"? Even people who go to
the same church, ostensibly believe in the
same god, all have different visions of what
God is in their head. Everyone is always going
to have a slightly different perception of
what that thing-- he, she, it, is. But at
the same time, it's a very particular thing
to each particular person.
And then you have the word "belief." Interestingly,
uh, the question of what the difference between
belief and knowledge is is not just a philosophical
question; it is an entire branch of philosophy
called epistemology. So obviously, uh, not
something to cover in a video blog, but the
longest-running definition is that knowledge
is belief that is true. Which is kinda strange
to get your head around, which is why there
is an entire branch of philosophy, uh, concerning
it.
When we believe something, we accept that
there is a chance that it's not true, but
we have faith nonetheless that it is true.
Like it's weird to talk about having faith
in things that you know, like I know that
this water is not going to poison me if I
drink it. Whereas, if I say that I have faith
that this water will not kill me if I drink
it, now I'm not so sure I'm gonna drink it.
But what really bugs me about the question
"do you believe in God?" is not that there
are many more interesting questions surrounding
that question, like "why do we ask it?" and
"what does 'believe' mean?" --is the motivation
behind asking that question. People who have
asked that question to me, or to other people,
I'm just curious, why do you want to know?
Because it seems like there's really only
two reasons to want to know the answer to
that question.
One: Because you're not sure yourself, and
you're trying to inform your opinion, and
you think that I'm some kind of authority.
To those people, I say: Thank you for thinking
that I'm an authority on this. I am not, and
that's going to have to be something that
you figure out on your own. And if anybody's
telling you different, uh, then they're wrong.
This is a question for you to answer for yourself.
There's kind of a 1.5 here, which is that
you want to reinforce your beliefs, and you
wanna feel like, "Oh Hank, he believes the
same thing as me, so now I feel better about
my beliefs." Well that's not actually going
to work, uh, for you; you have to feel good
about your beliefs for your own sake.
So basically 1 and 1.5, I'm not gonna help
you with that, uh, you gotta have to figure
it out on your own.
And the second reason to ask if someone is,
believes in God is kind of a shortcut to think
that you know more about that person because
of a very simple answer, which is dangerous.
This is the kind of pattern recognition that
we do constantly as people: we try to categorize
things. And that's usually really useful - until
you start dealing with people.
Sometimes I feel like when someone asks me
if I believe in God, it's like a blind person
asking if I'm black so that they can put me
in the right category. People are constantly
searching for little things that they can
use as markers to identify how and what people
are. Like, "gay people are all like this,"
"Christians are all like this," "atheists
are all like this." And that is - I mean,
duh - that's really dangerous!
So that's my biggest fear, that people are
asking because they want to inform their opinions
of me with this little one-word answer that
says so very little about who I actually am.
After you've formed a strong opinion of who
I am and understand how I live my life, that's
when I'll be comfortable telling you about
my beliefs and practices, which is that I
am a Satan worshipper who feeds on the blood
of newborn unicorns.
John, I will see you on Friday.